I'm excited about Avenue five Oh
freaking fun people love this show and
it's it's this great funny show that
takes place in the realm of it's a
science fiction science fiction category
it is it's a science fiction show but
not a traditional like Star Trek II yes
fiction show are you a fan of that genre
huge fan so anybody who knows me knows
that I'm really into Star Trek but also
Star Wars so both so I I got him afraid
to pick sides at the same time I so at
one day I get this phone call which is
like the phone call you dream of and I
get a phone call from my friend Daisy
Ridley and she goes so I'm on the set of
Star Wars and I would love to have you
come visit and I was shooting in London
and I was like oh my god oh my god yes
yes yes yes and I kept prolonging
because I had to shoot that day and all
sorts of stuff came up
and finally I'm the last thing that they
were shooting I said can I come she goes
well Josh she's British so this is my
impression of gazers she goes well Josh
it's a it's a closed set so I'm not sure
if you can come today and I said okay
well that sucks but she goes let me talk
to JJ JJ JJ Abrams I'm not like a
nickname so she does let me speak to JJ
she calls me up in she goes I don't know
how or why but JJ wants you to come
today it's nice so I'm like great so I
go and I'm so excited to see like a you
know like them getting on to like the
Millennium Falcon or just like something
like crazy right I got there and Ian
McDormand is in his Palpatine Alfa my
god
this next part is going to be a spoiler
alert for those of you who have not seen
Star Wars so I'm there and the first
dialogue that comes out of his mouth is
you are my granddaughter
while you're there while I'm there I was
being pissed yeah
that's a huge moment and you're
anticipating seeing the film and most
times when people come to the set
they're watching like oh this is the
scene where Han Solo takes a bite of a
sandwich and they get 15 shots of it try
it again
okay no let's take it from this angle
and you see that that's like hey come to
the set come to my said I'm night
Shyamalan come to my set Oh guess what
this is Bruce Willis and Bruce Willis
I'm just gonna shoot my scene I'm a
ghost like I don't remember that ever
being a line in the movie but yeah I
feel so honored but also so disrespected
at the same time that you would think I
wouldn't want to experience that with an
audience now one of the things that's
cool in your character in Avenue five
first of all I love this character
because he's he's sort of the the
billionaire center of it all right
you're you're running it's basically
you're running this how would you call
it it's not like a cruise line it's like
a space tourism like cruise yeah I would
literally say cruise on what you said
yeah and it's in the future and at 40 50
years in the future 40 years and and
your first of all your hair in this I
love the hair they gave the hair is
pretty incredible it's it's like a
Frankenstein version of Donald Trump
Boris Johnson and Philip Seymour Hoffman
by way of Jack Black all rolled into
what we have it right here
and you'll see that yeah
you could pull that off you don't I'm
not suggesting you need to no no I
understand no thank you we often say to
Andy you should grow your hair I would
get confused people would think I was
David Spade if you were a magician in
space yeah so yeah he's got a crazy
didn't you used to have when you were
younger you went through a blonde phase
I did I went through we're gonna show
this aren't we and I'm gonna be very sad
this is he step up without show yeah I
did I I went through a phase where I was
questioning myself as a human being and
I and I decided to change my look
completely it's for context mm was
really popular at the time that I did
let's take a look we'll see Billy Idol
Billy Idol Vincent D'Onofrio yeah
there's a lot going on we have a we have
a clip we have a clip here from what I
don't know this people won he was still
mad about the Star Wars story we have a
clip here from from Avenue v and and
this is a scene I believe where
basically things have gone very wrong
on this shift things have gone very
wrong on the ship and Herman Judd as he
often does assumes that he knows better
than all of the experts on the ship I
loved it yeah and your character is
because he's a billionaire and it's his
toy to play with he thinks he knows
about things but he has no technical
technological knowledge no technical
savvy I based him on Billy McFarland who
created the fire festival like a guy who
just like loves to talk a good game but
had no clue what's going on we also have
I'm gonna mention Hugh Laurie one of my
favorite actors yes he's the captain
Hugh Laurie is unbelievable as the
captain and and there's a lot of reveals
along the way that I don't want to spoil
for the audience and sure and the cast
is incredible Zach wood Suzy Nakamura
Rebecca front list goes on and on and
and yeah it's it's pretty special let's
take a look at this clip from Avenue v
it's maybe the worst disaster since
Google folded they'll figure this out
you know they turn the moon into a
massive jail they patented the liquid
glove how hard could it be to reset of
course 0.21 degrees it's like less than
half a right angle how can that make us
three years late Billy me okay so we
were going this way and now we're going
this way you see how my hands are moving
far apart mm-hmm and it's further in
reality obviously obviously that's
obvious right see no mmm that's well
that's not right it is right is it right
yeah no it would be a straight line no
no what
yes okay who's the engineer here who's
the genius
can any of you really frankly know
governance